so Donald Trump as expected is having a
hard time finding a way to fund his
great border wall he has suggested that
he'd be willing to shut down the
government in order to get funding now
originally we all know Pat that he was
going to get Mexico to pay for the wall
Mexico the former President Vicente Fox
made it very clear with language that we
can't use that they're not playing for
this blank wall and so the current
president also let it be know that
they're not paying for the wall Donald
Trump's trying to find a way to make
Mexico pay for the wall ultimately we
all knew Mexico was never going to pay
for the wall so now he's trying to
strong-arm Congress into finding funding
even in wrote out Attorney General's
Jeff sessions to say that we're going to
find a way to pay for this wall all the
way up to being willing to shut down the
government here's the here's the squeeze
he's finding out the political toxic
this I don't know there's any toxicity
thank you he's finding out the political
toxicity of shutting down the government
and so now he's rolling back this idea
he's backpedaling saying that maybe
he'll find funding in a different way so
perhaps he's gun-shy by maybe he's
finally been tamed and thinking that you
know when he came in he was guns blazing
thinking that he could do anything and
everything he wanted now he's realizing
he can't without Congress yeah and that
would be amazing if Republicans shut
down the government while they have both
houses of Congress and the presidency I
mean it kind of makes sense when Bill
Clinton was president or when Barack
Obama was collect resident because there
was disagreements there but over so
people in the same party interview that
make any sense yeah and I mean I believe
the deadline is coming this week and
it's ultimately it's Co siding with his
the culmination of his first 100 days
and so Donald Trump was looking for a
win ultimately he's just trying to find
some they've even floated this week
whether or not they would bring back the
health care debate whether they would
try to pass a repeal of Obamacare they
can't even get that done so Donald Trump
scorecard legislative scorecard is like
zero and ten in his contract for America
that he according to the AP when he said
to the AP that he never really had a
contract with them he had ten pieces of
legislation there that he was going to
go after in his first 100 days this was
his contract
and he's got nothing done of course you
have plenty of time afterwards but the
first hundred days is your honeymoon
period the timer II of the greatest
mandate people are in support of you
generally uh not so much in his case the
biggest accomplishment he can really
cite is the appointment of Neil Gorsuch
to the Supreme Court right all you had
to do was pick from a list of names and
get the Senate to approve it right
that's a bad report card that's a
horrible report card and it signals that
he is a that he's like I said he's been
tamed he's he's been broken he's been
housebroken into the reality that you're
not a dictator that you can't just come
in and one you can't tell a foreign a
sovereign nation what they're going to
do they're not going to you're not going
to force them to pay but then to you're
not going to tell Congress even your own
Republican Congress you're not going to
tell them that either do this or I'm
shutting it down he's finding out very
quickly how tenuous that situation is
and he talks a big talk when he's in
front of his audience and he has his own
little comfort zone there but he
actually met with enrique pena nieto a
little bit before the election right
they discussed payment for the border
wall that should be at the top of his
agenda for the meeting there but if you
didn't have the courage to do it he
didn't have the courage the demerit ii
and and and he was he was very
low-energy i remember their interview
very extremely low energy so I don't
think Donald Trump wants the job I you
know I wouldn't be surprised I'm just
going to say this but he can't handle
being in a position where he has to
actually answer to and consult with so
many people about every decision that he
wants to make I just don't see that he
really has the the the the longevity he
I don't think he's going to make it
personally I don't know if he's going to
make it and I'm sure he's the kind of
guy that will delegate out plenty of
responsibility we see Mike Pence taking
over a lot of areas as well as here cuz
one who goes and goes right but you
still have to conduct interviews you
still have to respond to the press you
still have to deal with Congress I mean
you can't just take away everything from
the job title I think he really believed
that he can rule this as a dictator like
for the very thing that Republicans
complain about with Barack Obama they
said he was ruling by eating is the very
thing that they wanted Donald Trump to
do and he's realizing now that even with
his own party he can't do it yeah me
just take a look at the executive orders
he's doing so at a far higher
and in Barack Obama over his previous
predecessors did and it's it's
particularly interesting because he has
both houses of Congress on his side so
you'd think he'd be able to pass
whatever legislation he wants to yeah
yeah absolutely I I'm tired of talking
about Donald Trump let's shift gears